rando pays vous propose cette semaine de
découvrir une randonnée incontournable
de cilaos à la découverte du site de la
chapelle
rendez vous au début de la rue
principale de cilaos
nous nous retrouvons jérôme turpin
accompagnateurs en montagne
curiosité exceptionnelle du siècle de
cilaos
la chapelle est un site très fréquenté
et apprécié bien que la randonnée soit
un peu plus dure que celle de la cascade
de bras rouge
elle est tout aussi facile d'accès
à l'essai
elle démarre en effet depuis la ville
même en suivant le petites routes
bétonnées qui descend dans le quartier
du bras des étangs et qui longe quelques
chants de lentilles
tu vois là
m
une fois engagé sur le sentier de petits
lacets permettent de descendre
tranquillement le long de la rabine
dijoux en direction d'eilat à cordes
voilà
weiss
g
m
là encore ce sentier roulant n'est pas
sans rappeler celui de bras rouge tant
au niveau du terrain que de la
végétation
il faut traverser quelques fois des
ravines dont certaines mettent à nu les
racines de filao d'un rouge éclatant
après un petit kilomètres de descente on
atteint cette intersection où il faut
bifurquer à droite en direction de la
creg qui sépare la ravine dijoux de
celle de bras rouge
une petite remontée d'une centaine de
mètres de dénivelé pendant laquelle ce
jour-là on observe des chocas on flaire
le choca il va se positionner dans tous
les fonds de ravine dans les secteurs un
peu chaud un peu sec
actuellement on voit qu'il est en fleurs
faut savoir le choca y fleurit tous les
deux en un
et il va fleurir une seule fois dès
qu'il a fleuri il donne sa graine les
graines tombent et le choca moeurs et
effectivement on peut voir soit des
chocas qui sont tous blancs fleuries et
des chocas qui sont pas fleuri à ceux
qui sont pas fleuri c'est les rejetons
qui sont tombés l'année d'avant une fois
arrivé sur la crête
on découvre pour la première fois la
chapelle dans toute sa splendeur
la chapelle c'est ce canyon très étroit
qui a été creusé au fil des siècles par
la rivière de bras rouge dans ce massif
imposant de syénite une roche très dure
d'origine magmatique auquel appartient
aussi le piton de sucre
cette formation c'est une ancienne
chambre magmatique ancienne chambre
magmatique qui a été refroidie en
profondeur il ya plus de deux cent mille
ans et l'eau après en venant sur ce bloc
là et rodez et a fait son passage à
l'intérieur c'est pour ça c'est comme
une saignée dans la roche qui est très
très fine
la courte descente vers la ravine bien
dégagée permet d'en prendre plein les
yeux
une fois la rivière de bras rouge la
progression devient plus difficile en
effet pour atteindre l'entrée du canyon
il n'y a plus de sentiers il faut
remonter le long de la rivière même
un balisage de cairns provisoire est à
trouver le meilleur chemin mais il
faudra parfois grimper sur des blocs et
souvent se mouiller
le niveau d'eau conditionne donc cette
progression à éviter à tout prix
après de fortes pluies
à mesure que l'on s'approche on se sent
petit face à un tel édifice naturel de
falaises vertigineuses de presque 100
mètres de hauteur encadrent l'entrée de
la chapelle qu'on aurait pu tout autant
appeler la cathédrale un spectacle
fantastique
le canyon humide et sombre invité par
les salangane s'enfonce en profondeur
on peut aussi avancer sur quelques
dizaines de mètres mais pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient l'explorer plus il faudra
se résoudre à nager un peu
ce que j'aime dans cette rando ses
nombreux points de vue qu'on a dès qu'on
commence là le sentier et puis après la
fin à l'extase découvre en dedans dans
cette chapelle dans ces deux gros blocs
rocheux on se sent un tout petit et là
on progresse dans la gauche c'est comme
si on part un peu vers l'inconnu on ne
sait pas trop qu'est ce qui lie après
après 7 après cette rivière
bon je vais dire que c'est accessible
presque à tout le monde il faut être un
peu débrouillard faut être un peu
débrouillard pas ou peu de l'eau et pas
avoir un peu pas avoir peur de mettre
les mains panthères escaladé un petit
peu grimper les rochers et puis le final
mettre les pieds dans l'eau peut pas y
aller toute l'année info faire
extrêmement attention du moment où on
pas si on voit que le temps est
incertain
il est préférable de rester coi de ne
pas partir parce que bon on est dans
l'élite rivière dans la ravine bras
rouge c'est hyper dangereux quand il
pleut dans les eaux notamment entre le
piton des neiges et le gros mende
l'eau peut arriver en vagues et là par
contre vous êtes pris dans la gorge de
la chapelle et l'eau arrivant va vous
vous sentez pas à quoi